so give it a chance because exactly that
spirit of jury you know be good to
yourself all that stay there don't stop
believin yeah I mean that's you know and
we've we've turned with the film
different film festivals and you meet
different people it can be at a bar you
know happy hour before the film or at QA
after the film and 95 percent of people
that come in introduce themselves always
tell me about it don't stop believin
story of their own I mean some very very
serious you know I was diagnosed with MS
and that was my song don't stop believin
my mother I passed a cancer that was my
song don't stop believin I mean the song
really really touches people and yeah I
think you know all my films and the
subjects are cheese are all very human
experiences just sort of show the
resilience of the human spirit and and
you know love and laughter and triumph
and sadness and all of that and I just
think that this is it this is something
very proud of you have a very powerful
emotional interview with Ross Valory in
the film and he talks about so many
people signed up for the fame and glory
of being a rock man but they don't
actually realize once they get it what
it entails and now they're too exhausted
to enjoy it or they don't realize what
responsibility is behind it so what was
going on the day that you got that
footage because it was incredibly moving
where he talked about it's hard to keep
up with people mm-hmm that maybe you
knew from the past you miss right stones
and you could see that he was processing
his own thing in his mind that I'm sure
many people
had to go through all the guys I mean
this is a testament to Ramona my
wonderful director everyone including
her now of course I think she made it so
easy for them to open up to her and that
interview was done in his home she spent
time with each individual person in
their home whether in Northern
California Portland Memphis and of
course the phillipines manila with our
now and just she just spent the day with
them and you know she hung out with them
saw their hobbies if they like to ride
the motorcycle and they you know their
music or just different things and then
she sat down and conducted this
interview and and that came out and that
it was interesting to me the tour normal
person has no idea how grueling tour is
I mean it's like literally like you
might go to sound check at 4 o'clock you
do sound check you hang around you eat
you do the show you shower you get on
the road and sometimes you might only
travel two hours sometimes you might
travel eight hours and then you sleep
for a couple hours you know usually kind
of when the Sun is rising to about 2:00
in the afternoon get in the truck
go to the venue do soundcheck and just
do it over and over and over again and
like as filmmakers our health was
deteriorating her sleeping was off our
eating goes off and I just can't imagine
having to do that and still look good
and sound good and be happy and perform
and just give 150% that these musicians
give it is you wake up and you don't
know what day it is you don't know where
you are you don't know what city you're
in when you're on tour it's just like
this constant motion
it's very grueling I mean these guys
just are amazing I thought it was
interesting to how our now really
stressed taking care of himself when so
many sex drugs and rock and roll is such
a he was drinking the tea
and he was he even said in another
interview that he really feels that he
needs 10 hours sleep sometimes and I
thought that was so great because he was
really protecting of course himself
precious being that he is but also his
voice that's why it's so amazing I mean
the pressure that was on him do you
figure if he just gets a cold or decided
decides he can't sing that night that's
20,000 fans I mean that's a big deal to
cancel something that big so you know
that the momentum and this tour was like
riding on him staying healthy and being
able to perform 110% every night and
give every single person what they paid
for in that city
you